okay this is a risky segment for me to
do
why is it risky it's risky because it's
wonky
and it's technical and i don't know that
people will like it this might be the
type of segment that ends up with like
you know 5 000 views on youtube
but about 10 people have emailed me and
they've asked me to do this they've
requested this so let's do it we are
going to talk about
two mechanisms which donald trump and
other rich people can use
to reduce the amount they pay in taxes
the two mechanisms are
tax loss carry forwards please don't
glaze over
tax loss carry forwards and asset
depreciation okay so donald trump's
taxes were leaked by
this blockbuster new york times report
in that new york times report we learned
that there were some years like 2016 and
2017
when donald trump paid 750 in total
federal taxes total for the entire year
in 10
of the last 15 years donald trump paid
zero in federal taxes how on earth is
this
possible well it's possible thanks to
something called
a tax loss carry forward and asset
depreciation i'm going to explain both
and you were very quickly going to see
how the tax code
favors the super rich as if you didn't
already know that
so what tax loss carry forward allows
you
to take a loss that happened in one year
and carry it forward
to future years to reduce the amount of
tax that you owe
so let's do like a very pedestrian
example compared to what donald trump is
doing
we'll do it with stocks imagine that you
buy twenty thousand dollars of some
stock
in one year and it loses fifty percent
of its value so your twenty thousand
dollars is now only ten thousand dollars
you lost ten thousand dollars great you
can deduct losses you can deduct
ten thousand dollars from your taxes
from the standpoint of paying
capital gains and it counts against your
gains beautiful
but imagine that in the year that you
lost the 10 grand and sold the stock and
realized that loss
you only made two thousand dollars from
all of your other stock sales
so you've got this ten thousand dollar
loss and only a two thousand dollar gain
well
great news you don't have to use the
full
ten thousand dollar loss in that year
you had a two thousand dollar gain
you'll take just two thousand dollars
from the ten that you lost
and you offset a two thousand dollar
gain with a two thousand dollar loss
you're at zero you pay no capital gains
and your other eight thousand dollars in
losses
can be carried over to future
years now maybe the next year you have a
really good year in stocks
and you realize seven thousand dollars
in gains well
you still have the eight thousand
dollars in loss
that you carried over you can use
another seven thousand
to offset the money you made in stocks
and again
you pay zero now that sounds reasonable
enough and it's simple enough
but that is small potatoes that's not
how trump takes advantage of it
real losses on the sale of stock
are not what donald trump is doing
donald trump is generating paper losses
with capital losses from huge hotels and
casinos so
here's an example in 1995
donald trump reported a loss of 916
million dollars on a casino
and we'll talk about how that loss was
generated
he then gets to take that 960 million
dollar loss
and offset 50 million dollars in taxes
per year
for 18 years in 2008
and 2009 donald trump declared a loss
of 1.4 billion dollars and
he extended the ability to carry these
losses forward indefinitely
in his own tax plan which was made
effective in 2018.
so trump can take that 1.4 billion loss
and just
carry it forward in definitely
offsetting future taxes
and the trick of it is that you can also
mess with how you declare these losses
so
we imagine listen i buy something for a
thousand bucks
and i sell it for 500. i really lost 500
that's a real loss of 500 with these
huge real estate transactions and
capital investments there are all sorts
of ways
that you can move around assets and mess
with the valuation of the assets i'll
get
back to that later to generate losses on
paper which didn't really happen in the
way you or i
think about losing money and you're
generating these paper losses which you
can then carry forward your average
middle class working person can't do
this
now the other tactic donald trump uses
where do you generate these losses to
carry forward
one of the ways you can do it is with
asset depreciation depreciation means
the value of an asset has gone down if i
have a car that's worth
you know fifteen thousand dollars when i
buy it and after a couple years it's
worth ten thousand dollars
that's depreciated by five thousand
dollars now with a huge real estate
portfolio
you know a hotel a casino a big office
building
you don't just buy it and deduct it as a
business expense
like i would do with like an audio cable
or you know i bought this new microphone
this year
i'm not going to depreciate this
microphone over the next however many
years it's too small of an expense
i'm just going to take it as a business
expense and deduct it right away
but with a huge hotel if you claim to
have a hotel worth 500 million dollars
and then now you claim you know the
hotel has aged the plumbing is older you
know you've got to flush the toilets 10
to 15 times as trump says
you could say the hotel was worth 500
million
it's now worth 250 million i can now
take 250 million dollars in depreciation
and reduce my taxes and this is where
the manipulations come into play
michael cohen has explained to us how
trump does this without actually
changing anything in the real world
if i can claim you know my 500 million
dollar hotel
it's really worth 600 million so what
that means is when it goes down in value
to 250
i'm not depreciating 250 million i can
now depreciate
350 million dollars and create
a loss carry forward that i can use for
the next however many years
it's all imaginary it's all merely
pushing paper
it's accounting mechanisms and we know
trump did this
the taxes prove it and michael cohen and
others have told us
donald trump for publicity purposes
or for tax purposes or for whatever
reason to get a loan
trump will inflate asset values when
it's convenient
or deflate asset values when it's
convenient these are the mechanisms
trump has used
this is how they work hopefully it's
useful to folks to understand it